okay
bingo
[Music]
[Applause]
great afternoon Chef wonderful here and
why are we talking today because it's
one of those days so beautiful out that
spontaneously 10 people are coming over
for a big cookout tonight yeah barbecue
so I want to talk about things you can
do quickly that are spectacular your
guests are going to love
and then be able to do them quickly
that's the whole key to this thing so
today we're going to talk about the
classic Mediterranean salad now a lot of
people think Mediterranean Talent salad
feta cheese oil vinegar
no no no no no I'm talking the real deal
the way they make it on the island of
Cyprus or Crete or southern Italy or in
Morocco that's what we're going to do
today and that involves some very
special items you've got to go fresh
we're going to go to the market together
here's what we're talking about we're
going to get cukes cucumbers but not big
fat cukes they don't have the crunch
they don't have the Crunch at all you've
got to go small cucumbers that's number
one okay so here are the cukes these are
Big cucumbers okay they're not going to
be as crunchy as small ones we want the
small cubes okay you see that
that's exactly what we're going to get
small cubes are way better crunchier
that's the key number two radishes yes
radishes they give it that certain June
that you want the radish has to be plump
and the whole thing about a
Mediterranean salad is surface area you
want to be able to cut up and slice and
dice but not into tiny pieces big chunky
bunky pieces lots of surface area for
the sauce I want to talk about thank
goodness is some radishes left here they
don't look picked over this there's
still plenty of good ones that we're
really looking for ones that are going
to Cube and quarter just beautifully
because we want that surface area it's a
beautiful bunch radishes they really
give you that texture and crunch of
course lettuce probably going to go
Romaine for this you can choose many
different lettuces I like Romaine okay
choices of lettuce always difficult
there's so many different ones in the
market I'm gonna go frizzy which is
really not an ancient Greek lettuce bite
we're going to use modern times to our
advantage and classic Romaine those will
be the two letter text so check this out
oh that's beautiful frizzy lettuce look
at that
issue wow that's just gorgeous let's get
one of those
[Music]
perfect
look at that Romaine that's beautiful
and we can go with the red tip or the
classic and we're gonna do
get one of each absolutely why not
[Music]
perfect also tomatoes are very important
and then for a little extra color
red peppers lots of great tomatoes to
choose from but I think I'm gonna go
right here why because they're going to
be much more interesting in terms of
texture and the way they can be cut
see if you can go any way you want you
can go minis you can go very specialized
of course cherry tomatoes can't go wrong
with that so San marzanos that's exactly
what we want that's just enough for
about 10 people I'm chopping them up
just nicely okay next up on the Hit
Parade bell peppers more color in the
salad right I said red bell peppers
check these out now that's a bell pepper
that's what I'm talking about fresh
crunchy perfect we'll just get two of
those that's it you don't need any more
I didn't say anything about cheese we're
not putting cheese in it but here's the
secret to make it a true Mediterranean
salad the way it was made two thousand
years ago was from the lemons pulled
right off the lemon tree
in the backyard of the home that was
being made and olive oil virgin olive
oil that means the olives never dated
anybody these have never gone out on a
date virgin olive oil you need that okay
these are perfect lemons organic really
big they're gonna be very juicy we'll
get six seven of these absolutely
fantastic organic lemons exactly what
you need lots of lemon juice the salad
requires all fresh and lemons give it
absolute zest the question we're going
to be adding at zatar and the virgin
olive oil that's right olives that never
dated anybody you're gonna just use
those two but the secret sauce that
nobody even thinks about that I learned
decades ago on the island of Cyprus in
the trotos mountains is
zatar
yep roasted and crushed sesame seeds
this is what you sprinkle on the salad
just before you serve it after you've
actually put on the dressing that you've
hand squeezed you're gonna hand squeeze
those lemons the zatar is the secret
sauce that makes everything just explode
to the upside
now there's one other secret ingredient
I didn't talk about and we'll let you
know now
yep
yep over top of the zatar and underneath
when you start the actual salad itself
chopped up partially finely chopped
parsley it gives it this
texture this taste this burst that
really goes well with the lemon and the
Virgin undated olive oil that's
fantastic any good Market is going to
have both kinds of parsley there's the
classic and then there's the curly
Curly's got a lot of crunch a lot of
texture you want both and luckily we
have both here check this out all right
that's classic parsley over here curly
parsley what are we gonna do we're gonna
get both
let's get a nice bunch of that perfect
and a really nice bunch curly
that's just beautiful and of course I'll
be serving tonight this is really
interesting I was just asking some of my
guests that are coming over what do you
want to start with because we'll serve
up some cheese and really what I found
amazing and this is happening a lot
these days it really kind of started in
Florida but Moscato so I'm bringing up
my O'Leary Moscato a sweet wine actually
first cultivated by the Romans yeah
Moscato the Romans that's right
it's got a beautiful kind of a flowery
vibe to it call it um
really Petals of roses but it's on the
sweeter side but you know you would have
thought okay let's go Chardonnay but
tonight we're going to have a little
splash of Moscato to start and then I've
gone into my deep dark Cellars I made a
special family reserve I named it Trevor
I knew my son this is a Cabernet
Sauvignon it's absolutely fantastic
we'll be serving that with the steak so
we're going to go the Greek salad start
with some cheese you know and basically
the Moscato and then we're gonna go to
Greek salad
steaks on the grill baked potatoes
and some grilled vegetables that's it so
simple you can whip that together in a
couple of hours that's what we're
talking about Chef wonderful to the
rescue
[Laughter]
it's very cool finding these olives
makes a difference in linear olives
we're going to cut them in half and add
them to the salad just a little spur of
the moment alexion
and here we are we're going to make this
salad now put everything out in front of
you
a little Moscato
oh that's beautiful you know I got to
tell you something a Shameless promotion
but
tell these wines at QVC for under 14 a
bottle and shipping is included try the
Moscato try the Chardonnay another
cabernetes solving you know try the
Pinot
so many Fantastic Riders let's start
remember I said we start with the base
we're going to talk about parsley I got
two different kinds now we're going to
chop it up put it in the bottom of the
bulb we're going to go back to the
parsley later but what I like to do is
chop I've got my blades out
as I need parsley you got to be very
careful with your fingers I learned this
years and years ago you have to Bunch it
up then make the cut okay just like that
you take your first pass then you Bunch
again it's bunch and cut bunch and cut
and be very careful with your
dexterities there your fingers because
this is how most people cut themselves
they get too close to the tips of their
fingers when cutting a dense parsley
Bunch you can't see the tips of your
fingers you gotta know your fingertips
know where they are all the time but
notice What's Happening Here slowly it's
getting a little more open
yes keep cutting cutting cutting cutting
cutting oh the smell of that parsley is
just fantastic I just love it the
texture of it keep cutting keep cutting
a motion forward on the cut is how you
want to do it not sliced backwards you
want to go into the bunch on a forward
cut you learn this some people say in
Chef school I say forget Chef School you
learn this when you make food the more
food you make the better you get at it
that's the whole idea I'm not against
Chef school I don't want to crap on Chef
school's butt you want to earn your
whites you got to make people happy with
what you're cooking that's the real test
not what you know degree you've got it's
when you make something do they love it
that's the key and they're going to love
this salad so we've got our first bunch
of the classic parsley cut and I think
I've got it just about right because I
want people to be able to parsley will
stick to the other veggies
itchy wow that looks good okay
in the base of the bowl it goes
that's how we start
all right next
the curly
frizzy exciting textured parsley
remember we're just cutting it up the
first time forward on the cut forward on
the cut forward on the cut watch the
dexters
watch the fingers
that's perfect then go back in
bunch and crunch
beautiful the smell of that fresh
parsley a lot of people don't know the
merits of parsley parsley as a certain
Genesee quarter any salad and it's very
very widely used in the Middle East on
all kinds of preparations including with
meat
and I'll tell you why because it adds
texture and a beautiful Aroma to the
nose that's just gorgeous there we have
it it doesn't take too long to get this
done
perfect
very nice bunch and crunch into the bowl
it goes forming the base forming the
base
oh that's gorgeous absolutely gorgeous
delicioso okay
what's next cukes all right remember the
cukes
let me just rinse off
now
I told you don't get giant cukes people
go out of their way to get giant cukes
big mistake they don't have the crunch
you want small cukes they're more work
you take off the tips on each side tip
removal that's it one cut down the
center watch the dexters here just like
that then you make
little
semis like that semi-moons
then going forward
it's a little bit of work here but
believe me this is perfect bite size
oh
crunchy so delicious
getting your greens going I got 10
people so I'm probably going to put in
eight cukes
approximately
tips off
there we go
then semi moons
you don't have to be perfect
you want a little you know diversity and
slice size
oh my goodness
foreign
we got to keep going on the cukes
fantastic
reward myself a little Moscato there
cheers
fantastical
that's beautiful
they're gonna love this salad tonight
okay now that's pretty good I think
that's good enough now remember I went
out of my way to so many different
tomato varietals but you want something
that's not going to fall apart it's
going to be you know get a giant tomato
it's not gonna have a lot of texture
once you start slicing it up you want
some kind of a tonality to your tomato
it stays together in the salad these are
perfect
so I'm going to take off each end
and what we're going to do here is we're
actually going to make a little
slices of tomato and not cut them again
so they're almost like little tomato
pizzas look at it this way see
now why are we doing that because
they're going to stay together they're
not going to break up inside the salad
perfect
let's try one
beautiful
you know tomatoes are actually a fruit
I know it's a big debate but now you've
got a large comat
gives it a really big presence
I love the way that looks that's just
absolutely fantastic you're really
building a piece of art here when you
make a salad like this so
think about it take off the ends
got to think ahead when you're buying
your produce what are you doing remember
forward and slice forward and slice
do not dice watch the fingers
perfect into the salad they go
remember you are going to toss this
thing
I love these Tomatoes just the aroma of
them so fresh
fantastic
forward and slides forward and slice
that's the way to go Don't Take Your Eye
Off The Knife you know you want to avoid
cutting yourself
don't do what I'm doing right now don't
cut when you're looking away from the
knife always keep your eye on the knife
and where it sits in the produce
there we go that's a secret listen you
learn that learn the world of Hard
Knocks
I'm thinking one more tomato okay you
got to kind of look at your portions
think about how it was gonna eat what oh
my goodness now
beautiful beautiful member Don't Take
Your Eye Off the blade okay
now
let's go
bell pepper a little trick to bell
pepper
smaller blade
go to the top of it and cut it out
straight down so you get the seed pod
watch your fingers watch your thumb a
lot of people got their thumbs on these
things
twist it out there you go now you cut it
in half
get any extra pulp you don't want around
and then you can just actually wash it
out and get rid of the extra seeds
[Music]
that's the trick
which I'm gonna do right now
now there's some debate about how large
the pepper should be you don't want it
to overstate its presence in the salad
oh yes rose petals of Rome that's
Moscato
[Music]
I have this peat out here for a reason
I'll tell you in a minute why
show you a Mediterranean trick I missed
a wonderful and I'm Chef wonderful what
does ERC stand for Chef wonderful the
employee retention credit what else does
it stand for cash flow this guy's so
smart and handsome go to wondertrust.com
to see if you're eligible
it's actually quite interesting on the
tongue the texture it's not bad for you
it's good for you
watch the blade watch your fingers I
keep telling people this
generally what I'm going to do this is
quite a bit of work is cut it into three
cut it into three
that's just enough presence in terms of
Peace size
the salad if it's a very long piece
maybe four but that's perfect
you got some presents there you don't
need tiny little slices you really don't
need to do that
okay maybe in this case I'm gonna go
four
you know I want I want each vegetable to
be able to make a statement
in the salad hi I'm pepper hi I'm tomato
how are you I'm a Cuke and look at me
I'm a radish if they're too small they
get nervous they don't want to speak
amongst the other produce pieces
you know what I'm saying yeah you didn't
think of that did you
okay
good
[Music]
beautiful there's a certain Zen to
making a salad you know it's very
calming very relaxing
when it was on your mind you stay
focused on what you're doing
very healthy that's why I like to come
up with some of my best ideas when I'm
cooking all right
let's talk about well Moscato for a
minute
thank you
okay
radishes they're all different sizes
that's interesting
you twist when you pull her out of shaft
you twist okay
I've already washed these so I'm going
to take off each end
then I'm going into four pieces that
means I get a pretty chunky bunky radish
oh
nothing tastes like radish I love it
[Music]
larger piece and put this up a little
bit more
you see any blemishes on the radish and
you can sometimes
cut them off on the outside
you want your salad to be blemish free
[Music]
they get bruised sometimes in the
picking but
perfect
[Music]
you want those chunks nothing looks like
a radish everybody's going to recognize
it
the red against the White
sort of like a watch band you know oh
look at that red band
I love this Patek rainbow I mean
I love cooking with Patek rainbows on
all right now I think a couple look at
this monster I love this guy
size of an apple all right
[Music]
oh I gotta reward myself from Moscato
it's beautiful all right getting towards
the end
we're going in now with two different
lettuces
the thing about lettuce
people cut it too small
if the personality is gone when you cut
it too small
God
so you really want to think about
lettuces have different textures
I love I love the different you know we
have so many different varietals we're
so lucky but what you want to do with
this is figure out what do I want to
show
[Music]
I mean I love what it's saying it's
almost like a flower and so maybe cut
off the stems a little bit okay
but also right at the bottom is some of
the most tender lettuce
so
keep an eye out for that but you see
what I'm doing here is we're keeping it
big enough so that it has a big
personality with this frizziness to it
you don't want to make it too small
people make that big mistake all the
time so maybe cut
an inch and a quarter
and let it fly into the bowl so that
you're really getting a lot of
dispersion
look at that beautiful beautiful look at
that just beautiful
so I'm taking it off in sections
see that
beautiful oh I mean the
texture is just
[Music]
will you marry me
[Laughter]
kind of like roses right
yeah I love it all right
okay here we go
[Music]
now we go a different direction lettuce
is going to be our big Baseline right
that's more of that than anything else
the Romaine red chipped lettuce we
bought that earlier looks so fresh it's
beautiful
I generally take out the outer pieces
just out of habit didn't really have to
this is so fresh
it's washed it's perfect okay
here we go
you know you're doing a great job if
you're making a total mess on your
cutting board
Baseline out there we go
oh my goodness fields we just
but what you do here
with Romaine people make this mistake
and I said it earlier with the frizzy
lettuce do not cut it too small
it loses its personality it can't speak
up in the salad it has no voice I'm
going an inch and a half okay
you get a pod get a pod
you break it up you put it in
it's perfect you get big beautiful
pieces
no question that's fantastic
love it inch and a half lots of
personality
watch your fingers
know where you are all the time
[Music]
then you get that crazy color look at
that look at that it's just
perfect that's our salad
however we've got to try it first
now because my guests don't arrive for
hours I wanted to keep fresh in the
fridge and I'll put the dressing on
right at the end but I want to show you
how I make the dressing this is the
classic classic Mediterranean way from a
thousand years ago
[Music]
they walk out to their backyard where
they'd already crushed the virgin olive
oil they had everybody had their own
olive trees I grew up in Cyprus we had
olive trees everywhere I mean it was
just these trees are thousands of years
old still making olives and everybody
absolutely everybody had orange trees
and lemon trees so lemons were right in
the backyard fresh lemons so there was
no waiting and you know going picking
them a day earlier or something you went
right outside and got them
obviously we can't do that easily in
North America but what we're going to do
is just show you in a bowl
you know I forgot something remember I
found those amazing olives
[Music]
I wanted to put a couple in the salad
because I wasn't planning on this
earlier by the way if you ever get a jar
that you can't open let me show you a
trick take the back end of a knife not
your ninja blades inexpensive knife bang
it on the dents a little bit then put it
under hot water
and sometimes you don't even need the
hot water just a little denting and
banging does it so
let's just check these out because if I
if they are what I think they are I
think I want to add them to the cell
I'm going to cut them in half
[Music]
oh that's
that's Karina
that's Cypress that's
I mean that is the Mediterranean
C washing up onto the rocks
okay so we're gonna put some in all
right
you don't put them in hold cut them in
half
why do you do that
or Surface area
[Music]
you want to make sure you get them
without all of pitch in them you don't
put pit at olives in a salad people are
going to break their dentures
they don't expect it that's the problem
so don't be very careful if you're going
to use olives in a salad not many people
do but make sure there's no pits
all right
[Music]
so my guests arrive in two or three
hours I want to pre-prepare so I'm going
to do a quick
toss
look at all those colors coming up look
at the parsley coming up beautiful
beautiful beautiful
absolutely fantastic
boy that looks great
oh beautiful okay
so what I wanted to do is just show you
take a little bit of it
put it in a bowl
so you can just sample your work but
this is how I actually put on the
dressing
all right
[Music]
this is how it's done right out of the
garden take a lemon
cut it in half
if it has seeds don't worry about it
people know what seeds are when they see
them it makes it authentic
take the lemon
squeeze it right over your salad just
like that yeah
the tactile experience is absolutely
perfect
beautiful
then
our virgin olive oil remember I said
these every one of these olives never
went on a date this is a true virgin
olive oil
beautiful beautiful
then
let me just wash we just get the oil off
of pans okay because I want to show you
something the real
Secret
zatar
and what is autards a Mediterranean
spice it's centuries old it's ancient
it's
baked or cooked sesame seeds crushed
oh yeah
[Laughter]
and it reminds me
reminds me of the ocean
now let me show you a little trick
remember the peat I showed you earlier
we want to sample a salad yeah you could
bite it put it on the fork let me show
you something we do
we did very often that we used to do at
picnics in the trotos mountains
just as a snack the kids are getting
hungry you want something to give them a
bite you know you're still roasting the
meat on the spit but just something to
snack on you take the salad and you open
a pita like this and you put it in
that's after you've dressed it just like
this
with all the different elements and
textures
this is so delicious
just like that
we call it a Mediterranean Taco you
ready hi I'm Mr Wonderful if you own a
business and have employees you need to
check out the ERC program at
wondertrust.com there's money waiting
for you I did which is why I have time
to tend to my precious little trees he's
such a good boy
bingo
oh are you kidding are you kidding oh
what are we talking about here
we're talking 15 out of 10. this is
unbelievable
wait wait one more boy
that's insane you must make this salad
you must get the zodar that's the secret
that's the secret but also the fresh
lemon virgin olive oil all these
different textures
I mean sorry I'm just
I mean this is the dance of Joy here
they're gonna go nuts today
I mean
that is just
are you kidding
oh wow
hmm
sure I mean I had no idea I knew it was
going to be good but that's good
everything's coming together in this
salad all of these different textures
everything's fresh
fresh lemon virgin olive oil the zatar
The Secret of zatar makes the salad
explode
[Music]
I mean
I should set up a stand on the street
right outside right now I should charge
15 bucks for one of these
I mean come on this is absolutely
spectacular I got a food truck going
that's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna quit
everything and hit the road with a food
truck
with their salad
okay let's sum it up here one of the
great Pleasures in life
is to cook is to make things
is to work with your hands and knives
and ingredients and blending and boom
when you get it right
it's a freaking Mona Lisa that's what
I'm talking about here this salad is a
Mona Lisa okay maybe it sounds a little
aggressive but it isn't it should be in
the Louvre this should be in the loop
right now I should be standing with it
like this
that's a picture now that is how you
make a real
Mediterranean salad
try it everybody around you is going to
love you and say make it again
don't forget
[Music]
zatar
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
everything else is false
tonight we will try the very best on
Earth thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
[Applause]